uh let me grab the
um uh let me grab the instagram here
throw it back up on the feed because
i think this will be interesting to
unpack guys if you're enjoying this
uh hit the like button and um there's a
couple of
super chats coming through which i'll
get to in just a bit so just so just
bear with me for
a little bit as i kind of unpack this so
this is the
last post where he appears in her
timeline june 15
2019 where she's announcing moving to
california
she's talking about a kick-ass job in a
house and all these goals
and she's starting to um churn out these
uh posts with her pictures
that are in alignment with the instagram
influencer the life
coaching model that she starts to lean
into uh she's probably uh
there you go the hashtags beach babe
dream big follow your heart
vibes life coach life coaching
rise and sign [ __ ] that's not
something
a wife would be saying in my household
lgbtq
say yes mindset so she's boss babe is
another big red flag guys i've talked
about boss babes before because these
are women that try to compete with you
and a woman that tries to compete you
with you will never respect you
so let me pull this up and let's kind of
go back through this timeline a bit and
see how this
unfolds so this is all prior to
she's got tattoos on her wrist here
already this is all prior to the
uh separation and i guess moving to
california here's a picture of her
getting a tattoo which is never a good
sign
i don't know why she looks like she's
got a big wrist tattoo and one down her
the inner arm worthless bundles
hashtags a lot of pictures of her and
look at me and my dress and here i am
looking pretty are you ready for more
one of her girlfriends looks like an
amsterdam
a lot of her still it's all still fully
clothed though
she's just doing makeup okay so this is
one about money i love money
i like it a lot i used to resent it john
and i worked harder and longer hours yet
every year we managed to make less money
how could i not be resentful money is
important right hypergamy dictates that
women are always going to look for the
best deal that she can get
i don't know what was happening directly
in the marriage but clearly
there wasn't enough there to go around
if she was struggling with money and
was looking to level up in a sense i
don't know if this is the
this is a porsche cayenne suv
um i'm assuming this is probably a
mid-range model doesn't look like a
turbo so maybe about 70 75 000
it might cost i i think those red brake
calipers
indicate that it is a higher level uh
model just out of
personal knowledge uh but it's a
beautiful car
whatever it costs uh and they're not
cheap to own or maintain
and it you know those don't look like
stock wheels either
so she's really enjoying it no she likes
the porsche cayenne and here we go
taking selfies in the mirror
so this is a mother of three
this is this is what she's getting up to
and she's still married to
john now she's still wearing clothes
here fellas now she's tattened up her
body
again we're we're going back in the
timeline
i'm assuming there's going to be more
yeah more pictures of the kids my three
babies
it still blows my mind their souls were
entrusted to me and how grateful i
am i don't know that they're going to be
grateful when they have end up in school
and their
schoolmates find out that mommy gets
naked for forty seven thousand dollars a
month on only fans
let's see what else we can unpack here
now we have another
car here this this one's a little bit
less flashy than the porsche this looks
like a toyota corolla
this is kind of your basic beige family
sedan except for it's red
this is back in may of 2017. this is
prior to california still
a lot of pictures of her still she's got
the feminist t-shirt on here with the
wrist tattoo showing
very subtle but true wow very very
subtle change in
you know here's her i did it you guys
masters of
arts and leadership this is what aaron
cleary would call a useless degree
by the way i think it's noteworthy that
she has an undergraduate degree
in broadcast journalism so one way or
another she was getting in front of a
camera
whether she was going to be a newscaster
or doing what she's doing now
and she's a very very good speaker so
she's parlayed that talent
into monetizing it to make a very
healthy income
so she got to speak at her final senior
chapel yesterday because
guess who's graduating from seminary
this weekend
this [ __ ] hmm i don't know that's a
red flag there that's not
that's not how a wife should be speaking
a mother of of three
yeah feminist another feminist t-shirt
another red flag right there
it's it's no surprise that in the
podcast interview she was using
um words like oppression and privileged
males
um to be a feminist you have to
like you have to have a victim mindset
there has to be an oppressor
and that's just what they go seeking i
always tell guys to avoid that
if you if you see any sounds of that
like if you hear any sound bites around
that that's something that you certainly
want to stay away from because it does
end up becoming problematic for some
guys
and in this case it did still fully
clothed but still taking a lot of
selfies in the mirrors
a lot of the feminists and the wrist
tattoo photographs still showing there's
a skydiving
still fully clothed though and she's of
course wearing more clothes we're on the
black lives matter trail this is in 2019
before the
uh the big uh rigmarole you know from
this year
um this is a skydive event yeah
family photo here you try to capture the
perfect family photo you decide to post
them all
that's a good looking family but i
didn't see her post a lot of them in her
instagram timeline it seemed a lot of
her her her and her
yeah in front of a ferrari yeah as a
leader you are here to create and
contribute not merely to consume so stop
scrolling and start contributing ladies
get out there leave your husband and
live your best life
the world needs your voice your take
your spin your personality
no it doesn't really a lot a lot of
virtue signaling still with the t-shirts
and the in the post let's jump out of a
plane again looks like this is back in
california
this weekend while in california i
turned a three million dollar house it
was so beautiful inspiring but i
couldn't afford it of course
the deep pool front yard well she's
ambitious i mean you know let's give her
that
oh here we go the bathing suit
photographs start
i wonder if this is the point where he's
basically saying no
i don't think so nicole i don't know but
he
he almost kicks himself for
waiting so long to see a lot of there's
a lot of airbrushing touch up
in the photographs over here there's
some there's some work that she's
getting
done there with the photographs um
i mean she's not particularly like
figurish like she's very squarish
it's not it's not the conventional like
feminine hourglass
uh desirable shape that you think that
you know guys would pay for
photographs on but strangely you know
they do
a simp in his money is easily separated
by somebody like this with a story
behind it about how she's living her
best life being a boss babe i guess
yeah so
and this is all just the family stuff on
the tour i guess a lot of pictures of
her
posing right a lot of like this is this
is a lot of red flags right like if
you're married you don't
you don't allow this sort of behavior to
take place
i mean she's not getting a lot of
attention right 56 likes 61 likes but as
we go to the more recent stuff towards
the top here
where she's now become a complete
uh instagram only fans icon
um she's got clips here with jimmy
kimmel this is
her more recent only fans photographer
this is a clip from the new york
uh article bisexual pastor turned
stripper has never been happier
odd because again in the podcast she
called herself queer not bisexual
but lots of photographs here revealing
there was one uh there was one
where she was bragging as she was
breastfeeding one child doing the hair
while the nine-year-old was taking the
picture you guys must see
anyway there's a lot of modeling
pictures here
a lot of modeling pictures
endless right like this is this is
obviously after they
they parted ways he doesn't appear again
after that one photograph
so now she's living her best life she's
a life coach
exactly the floodgates have opened yeah
yeah there's tyrone again she's
obviously having fun now
picture picture picture she has uh
about 1800 followers at 25
a month that's how she got 47 000. what
about the 21 and 22 year old
knockout beautiful women how many
followers do they have they may they
must make
well over a million dollars a year well
apparently she's in the top
um i think
like 10th of a percent of creators for
only fans from what i understood from a
story
but yeah like here's the post that i'm
talking about like this is a mother of
three when a model
is a mummy so she's calling herself a
model
this photo was taken by so her
nine-year-old is taking this photograph
this is motherhood unfiltered fresh out
of the shower brushing
the six-year-old's hair while the
four-year-old is insisting on
numbs before school and my nine-year-old
so sweetly standing
by waiting for her to turn for a hug and
kiss before leap
see this is the narrative that they sell
um
i've often said that that you know what
you're gonna see
on people's uh social posts as a
highlight reel of their lives it doesn't
reflect the accurate
you know the accuracy of it um this is
not all rainbows and butterflies and
sugars and spice and all things nice for
every single day of her life like like
she's she's gonna have
have struggled here and there for sure
more often than not
and turning to only fans let's see uh
yeah 24.99 a month
more info uh oh she has an amazon
wishlist here of things that you can buy
her even though she's making fifty
thousand dollars a month you can buy her
the
tantus strapless strap-on vibrator in
purple fellas if you'd like to
uh order one uh spare pants juice mail
weighted blanket bunny ear headphones
and some lingerie so
um interesting that um you know she's
got links there for that but she does
she does a good living um on her
facebook page over here again this is
all public right like you know you just
click it
off her website there is a brag here
about the 47 so i want to hear from you
what's
what are the implications of the why
doesn't that go away
anyway underneath here it says do i have
to refresh it let's try this again
because it has the amount i think it was
47 thousand dollars she's bragging about
so i want to hear from you john what are
the implications
there it is 47 so i just had a 47 000
a month holy [ __ ] it happened it really
often happened
there's a lot of swearing for a mother
that's in church
um so gross is 47 000 so net is 38 000.
so you're right john what is it 20
right according to the website uh only
fans
that's what they take
you